being a technology enthusiast I love to
learn and evaluate about new emerging
technologies hampson third party I'm
working as an embedded UI expert in
Nilachal scheme I've been working in
this industry last talia's and I was
looking for some new challenges when I
came to know about simpler PGP program
in artificial intelligence and machine
learning I have no such fun to take
complete diverse and in my career but
I'm keen to learn these technologies and
to combine my multimedia expertise with
with a IML knowledge and built a career
over it it was early 2019 and I was
thinking to take next to consciousness
steps towards up is killing my friend
advised me to take a management course
but I'm more passionate about technology
set up the idea of pulsing management at
the same time in my organization I got a
small fee USB to work on where I have to
use a IML constant to the cognized a
mess this is the tailing point and this
taken my interest in topology if you
think AI is FD real now all the big
multimedia companies such as Netflix
Amazon fine YouTube users ml model for
movie recommendation Alexis piece the
carnation is involved by AI some keen to
learn these technologies and exposing a
personality beyond values I realize this
is a right time for me to to have a
formal training and elevate my knowledge
and abilities when I was certain about
learn in this technology I started my
research
because I love my job I want to take up
online so that my work remains
unaffected I was contemplating three
more options along with simpler PCB
program after comparing learning curve
which is ko and cost-effectiveness I
chose simpler also simpler collaboration
for diversity caught my attention
because it has no value and
determination across the globe I am
ruling to the last year this course
involves lot of complex topics such as
statistics and mathematics having
engineering background I find it a bit
challenging in beginning but I must tell
out and struck the support of explaining
each and everything with the example
simpler community has been a github of
giving my doubts using LMS system I'm
able to streamline my learning and find
it interesting because of the video
tutorials and it lifts the unifications
and I'm excited about completing my two
modules data science and machine
learning I am looking power to learn
more that's a force and holding
companies I have a message to share the
global learning community that this is a
time to enhance your skills and
knowledge as you staying at home due to
virus of faith we are saving lot of
commuting time to a workplace and this
time should be used statistically
towards building learning and personal
development
we will soon win a ball against coming
90 but when we come out we must emerge
as a better person I choose simply learn
for the upscaling accept
it's time for you to learn